thank God for giving me you first number
one song from a married couple since Tim
McGraw and Faith Hill that is a pretty
cool stat to have under your belt can't
tell me that I was like wow that's wild
oh my gosh and to perform it together in
Austin on the stage of the CMT Music
Awards will your daughters be in the
audience to see this moment from their
mom and dad no no no
they're just still so little like Cody
just turned a year old I mean bedtime's
like 6 45 okay 7 15 maybe in a couple
years she'll say Kane's not only
performing with his wife live at the CMT
Music Awards April 2nd he's also
co-hosting alongside his good friend
Kelsey ballerini Kelsey told us that she
will do as many wardrobe changes as CMT
will let her how many wardrobe changes
will you do or you want to keep it
simple they'll probably be two or three
well tonight Kane is rocking a flannel
for CMT storytellers Kane Brown and only
we were on set
why was it important for you to include
for my daughter on the setlist uh I mean
it's telling a story you know I grew up
growing up without a dad and
um you know I just
being a dad is just an amazing feeling
we're gonna see more of you on TV you
recently filmed for fire country it was
super fun
and
it was a lot of action for Max I love
you you made it so easy I can't wait to
hopefully do it again
[Music]
foreign